and then we're going to be able to
utilize them the programs we have
whether it's fast track or there's one
start with us closing funds but to
reality that is it's going to help
thousands upon thousands of Missourians
and prepare them for the workforce of
tomorrow and to give Missouri a
competitive edge against other states
that were competing with every day to
get those things done and by doing that
we'll really be able to help us focus on
the next generations coming up and what
we will allow them to be prepared for
the work especially those high demand
jobs that we've talked about all year
and we all know no matter we live in the
state of Missouri how important that is
for all the reasons of the state to meet
those demands the other thing you've
heard me talk about since I become
governor is infrastructure today the
house finished up the bonding bill that
was out there it was a piece of
legislation will be coming to my desk I
look forward to that's coming here too
when the day comes I look forward to
signing that bill because when you look
at what we did for the state of Missouri
in that bonding proposal how it affects
almost every region in the state of
Missouri doesn't matter what's urban
area rural area it's going to have an
effect on everybody throughout this
state and to be able to do that by
working together with the House and the
Senate is what we should do here in
Jefferson City sometimes doesn't my role
as governor trying to figure out how do
you come to solutions instead of
gridlock and I'm really proud of what we
did we'll do here in Missouri this year
and if you compare this and what
sometimes the federal level does you
know what gridlock is and what it costs
and I think all through this session
through this week we're going to try to
work together trying to find the
solutions for major issues and I'm just
so happy that it'll be done when this
infrastructure infrastructure package
will be completed with a five-year step
plan Kubota they'll be over a billion
dollars worth of construction that will
come out of this for the state of
Missouri and that means thousands upon
thousands of jobs throughout this state
which is important to me and I think
that's going to make our economy will
even become stronger as we know we have
record numbers of
employment in our state and if you
looked at the tax incentives on the
national level the state level what
that's doing for everyday people to put
money back in their pockets and to be
able to get those things to the state
level is this going to be a great time
for people to invest in Missouri I think
we're gonna have a great opportunity to
bring businesses in the state like we've
never had before and to grow our
population but more importantly trying
to keep our own men and women here at
Missouri trying to keep those kids
graduating out of high school and
colleges try to give them the
opportunities they need to stay here
right in Missouri because nobody will
build our economy and better than people
that are from Missouri and people
literally and then people will come here
someday because of what the example we
said on that
needless to say agriculture is always a
huge deal for me I'm always going to
advocate of agriculture that's pretty
well given most of you know that but
we've had some really significant
movement this year in agriculture and
you know what the director director Qin
has helped with that moving those bills
forward you know it's opened the doors
for Missouri farm families to meet
growing world food demands and ensure we
keep more of that production in our
state and when you look at agriculture
sometimes it's one of those things
that's overlooked sometimes in our state
and when you look at the demand on
agriculture for the future of the
country and the future of the world and
you think you have to double the
production of agriculture in the next 40
years which took us 240 years to meet
the demands of the world there's going
to be some great opportunities there
through to technology through science
we're going to change the way we're
doing in agriculture in this state to
meet those demands and we're so
fortunate to have agriculture in our
state to be part of that industry and
you know we on the tort reform issue
when you had venue joiner and improving
businesses the business climate
providing another boost to our strong
economy you know downsizing government
was one of the things we did you know
were some of the things we don't
especially in Corrections that we've
done an Ann teer the rector's here with
us today but when you talk about
shutting down a crutch
facility which has never been done the
state of jury that I'm aware about to
really start trying to focus on people
how do we streamline that and how would
sure make sure that people are
incarcerated or getting the skills they
need to go into the workforce is to the
building more prisons and I've said all
along I don't want to do that anymore
but I can't say enough for what she's
done for the Department of Corrections
and those things that she's brought
forward to take care of our employees
the concerns that we've had in the state
of Missouri what she's done to do that
so with that is another issue of my
closing that one Penitentiary down will
save twenty million dollars right off
from state government so when we talk
about downsizing and streamlining I
really mean those things are just not
buzzwords that you normally hear you
know I asked the director of economic
development which will talk about it
here in a minute
but his agency had over 800 people you
know and frankly it wasn't very
efficient it wasn't efficient like we
want it to be when you start talking
about workforce and where we're going
and tomorrow as part of recruiting
businesses and taking care of people to
be trained to that workforce and we're
going to take that down that economic
development arm down from over 800 down
to less than 200 by August and make sure
they streamline on what they're supposed
to be doing
and not a lot of things they probably
should have been doing in the first
place so I'm looking forward to making
those streamlining government for that
and I think that's really important when
you do that you know the other thing I
want to talk about is the budget process
that we went through this year you know
when I started out the budget I didn't
know what to expect we know where
revenues were and all along you know we
were concerned about those numbers when
I put the budget together this year I
tried to look at the budget from a
business perspective that was long
overdue for me to do that I tried to
look at okay how can we get the job done
in Missouri we streamline government we
are very responsible taxpayers money and
how do I make sure when something maybe
doesn't go like we expect it to go what
do you do so when the initial thing is
we try to put a pretty good budget
together
conservative budget together and one of
the things that I was really proud would
get done is in my administration is that
we left one hundred million dollars on
the bottom line in case we need four
unseen things that could occur here in
our state and you couldn't see any more
time of it when you talk about tornadoes
that have hit the state recently when
you talk about flooding all the way from
the Missouri River to the Mississippi
River two other things that occur just
in everyday businesses like everybody
else runs your businesses it's always
good for most of us we have to live our
lives Tory have to be conservative and
save our money in case we do have things
on that the other thing is that it's
proud of when you just the internet we
put more money on broadband I know the
director bad folks are very happy with
that most people were sort of trying to
make sure they have access to broadband
on that the other thing was we fully
funded the k-12 education again and I
think that's the third year in a row
we've done that it's truly trying to
focus on making sure our kids have the
education tools they need to be
successful in the near future and
finally just to creating the culture
alive in our state you know I've been
pretty clear where I've been from day
one right to live as we see if we just
passed a piece of legislation here that
you all the little that web take
semester all the way from this state for
the national level but I think that's
important I think that showed
Missourians values and it's a piece of
legislation that will be signed in the
near future but I think always always
it's the most important to protect
women's health and advocate for the
unborn that's always important to me and
so with that I'm gonna let director
Dixon say a few words on the economic
Belmer go here hi I'm Rob Dixon I'm the
director of the Missouri Department of
Economic Development this has been a
historic legislative session for
economic development in the state of
Missouri the fact is our state has not
been competing well in economic
development in many cases were falling
behind other states across the country
the reason for that is because we did
laser focus on the top issues facing
business really workforce development
infrastructure the governor's laser
focus on those issues the Legislature's
laser focus on those issues have now
helped us that the course of this
legislative cut played at legislative
session to develop a set of tools that
will allow Missouri to compete with
anyone in the country to compete with
the other the best states in the country
and to win and I wanted to talk about a
couple of those things specifically
obviously this earlier this week there's
a lot of discussion on Senate bill 68
inside